we're turning to uh this man to make
heads or tales of the 9-0
supreme court ruling dunking atop the
ncaa today
and what that means for the future of
the economic model
of the ncaa which is uh here's your free
education
and uh we'll take everything else
essentially uh but i know there's a lot
of gray area which is why we're having
uh the sports professor and the man in
charge of the tulane sports
law program gabe feldman back here in
the rich housing show how you been gabe
i'm good rich how are you you've taken
the uh retirement of coach cawell
i assume right you've been in the two
denial every year he may change his mind
okay so what the heck happened in the
supreme court today
for a nine nothing ruling gabe
it's a remarkable day there's not much
that nine justices on the supreme court
can agree on
but one of them is that the ncaa is in
violation
of antitrust law through its
restrictions on college athletes
and the decision itself is actually
pretty narrow and pretty modest because
it only applies to
what are called education related
benefits so this would be
musical equipment or computers or
internships and
uh things like that so it's not going to
have a massive
short-term impact but the bigger impact
is that the court basically said
the argument that the ncaa has been
using for decades to justify
all of its restrictions on college
athletes is no longer valid
so this will certainly open the door
to more antitrust litigation that might
try to
take apart every rule that
has been really fundamental or
foundational for college sports and may
open the door for athletes not only to
be paid for their name image and
likeness which is
the story this month but also just to be
paid to
or to be paid to come to school so let's
before we get to
the huge potential uh tidal wave
let's just talk about what we saw today
what
what will now change in the world of
ncaa sports change
as of now is that schools cannot agree
to restrict these education related
benefits so there was a really broad
lawsuit and ended up getting narrowed
down to these two issues and one of them
was
what they call in-kind education-related
benefits so there are restrictions on
how many uh computers or musical
instruments or pieces of science
equipment
that athletes were permitted they're no
longer allowed to restrict that
again that's not going to be a major
change for athletes to get some more
musical instruments science equipment
they're also going to be able to get
internships and scholarships post
eligibility which is not
insignificant but again not going to
suddenly change the model and lead to
millions of dollars come in
and they're also going to be allowed now
the schools to pay
up to about six thousand dollars for
academic achievement awards
um but they can limit it below but they
could limit it any higher than six
thousand dollars
so that's the immediate impact pretty
modest if that were it
i think the ncaa would declare victory
and go back to their business as usual
but it's the reason why the court held
all that stuff to be illegal
that's more important than what they
actually held to be dave
feldman director of sports law of tulane
law school
uh right here on the rich eisen show and
uh i think we let's talk about the the
what next
because you said that the ruling uh
invites potentially more bites at this
apple
um and for for student athletes who want
to get paid
um for their services and
usually you know you read an opinion if
i'm not mistaken
because i do have uh a degree from your
esteemed
uh institution of higher learning that
you still have yet to sign and make it
official
okay honorary honorary degree my bad
right
um that uh that you then look at some of
the concurring
opinions and the brett kavanaugh
concurring opinion basically says
bring it let's go i'm ready to to make
this
much larger and pay athletes am i
reading that correctly
that shows how much your honorary degree
has actually paid off
you've read it beautifully you've
explained it beautifully so there's two
things one is the
the full opinion from the eight justices
that says
we're just going to look at the narrow
issue and that narrow issue is those
education related benefits
those restrictions are illegal but even
in that opinion they said look
although we're not addressing
pay-per-play or nil or all that
other sort of stuff the reason for the
ncaa's
protection under antitrust law that
they've gotten for the last 40 years
doesn't exist anymore the world as it
was
back 35 years ago when the supreme court
first gave the ncaa attention trust
protection has changed
and they are not entitled to this
anti-trust protection but we're only
addressing this one little issue
kavanaugh came in and said i know we're
only addressing this one little issue
but this whole thing stinks and college
athletes are being exploited
these restrictions would be illegal in
any other industry they should be
illegal here
this predominantly affects black
athletes and
i mean he dropped the hammer on the ncaa
and and it's remarkable because
this is a pro athlete pro labor decision
and it came from arguably the most
conservative
justice on the supreme court or
certainly one of them so if the ncaa
gets its most scathing anti-ncaa
judicial opinion of all time and it
comes from a conservative supreme court
justice
that's not good news for the future of
the status quo for the ncaa well how
does that happen does that just
kavanaugh
i'm serious does he walk into robert
chief justice john roberts office and
say hey
i want to add something and and and
do they read it first before saying okay
like literally how does
something so um remarkable
in terms of saying let's keep you know
uh congratulations ncaa not only do you
lose this non-nothing but
you know we we've just gotten started
essentially
well how does that happen yeah and
that's that's the prerogative of each
justice they can write the concurring
opinion they can write a dissenting
opinion the other justices have a chance
to read it and have a chance to join it
if they want so they could essentially
co-author it right
he was alone on this one so um
they can't stop him from writing it but
you will notice or one will notice that
they don't
criticize it or try to limit it in their
main opinion
so this may have been the other justice
is saying
you know feel free to write it um we're
not going to join it we're not going to
comment on it
we think it's beyond the scope of what
we were asked to do but
it's it's still pretty telling now
obviously if more justices had signed it
would have been even more troubling
for the ncaa um but this is
you know about as bad as it could have
been unless
everybody had signed in on uh kavanagh's
opinion and then that had been the
actual opinion
in this case so the the i guess the one
piece of solace they can take from this
is that it was only kavanaugh on that
opinion and then in terms of my reading
of things
along with my honorary degree from
tulane law
um from the sports law um
organization that you head up there gabe
uh
my reading correct is that what makes
now stop me
uh people will be saying you know this
is crazy that the ncaa uh
steps on its own you know what if is it
true that the ncaa
asked this like put this before the
supreme court after they got dunked on
by lower courts as well that so in other
words this
ruling this nine-nothing ruling
against them and then this concurring
opinion
where brett kavanaugh essentially lays
out a road map
for the entire apple in cart being
turned over
um was the ncaa's doing
essentially in some ways yeah you could
i'll give the football analogy although
the incidentally
lost at the lower courts it was a pretty
small loss
so it was as if they had gotten the
field goal and then took the field goal
off the board
um and then allowed the plaintiffs to
come in and score the touchdown
because what the ncaa i think i
butchered that
no but i think you nailed it actually
okay
all right right you said the slam dunk
and i was trying to find a layup analogy
didn't really work but the um what the
ncaa asked the supreme court do and keep
in mind the plaintiffs
did not ask the supreme court to hear
the case that they were going to take
their
their field goal and and go to halftime
um
but the the ncaa did appeal
because they wanted the shutout they
wanted
to end all these cases they didn't want
the next plaintiffs to be able to say
look what the ncaa is doing now this is
illegal
they wanted the supreme court to come in
and say in 1984 in this famous border
regions case
you said we can basically do what we
want we want you to reaffirm that now
and and reaffirm that we are the ones
who get to govern
college athletics we get to decide how
much college athletes get paid
and we get to create this product and
this product is based on the fact that
the athletes are not paid
that's what makes it different from pro
sports they were hoping with a very
conservative court
one of the most conservative courts of
all time that they would have the votes
to do it
that they would have enough justices who
would say you're right super uh
we are going to give you more protection
obviously didn't turn out that way right
now they're going to get less protection
and maybe even less again for the next
lawsuit but
what this might lead to in terms of next
steps is
for the last six months year the ncaa
has been
at in washington dc asking members of
congress to give them an anti-trust
exemption
because they were worried if they didn't
get an antitrust exemption they would
keep being sued under
antitrust law and eventually lose and
that's where they are now
so the story may not be over yet it's
over in the court
um until the next lawsuit is brought but
it may be that congress comes in and
says we don't want college football and
college basketball to be destroyed we're
going to come in and give you an
exemption
or just like it wouldn't actually
destroy it isn't that what the ruling
said here
is that that that's a fallacious
argument that that's what the lower
court said too is that
this doesn't destroy it this is just the
way that you're doing it and as a matter
of fact it's illegal
when from an anti-trust perspective here
and i don't know i i was following a
little bit what was going on in the
commerce committee in the senate gabe
and it sound doesn't sound like
any of those lawmakers are considering
giving them an anti-trust exemption
anytime
soon so um what what what is i guess
in final the next step here like does
this
because right now from what you're
describing you know now
some of the student athletes might get
more computers and more
of that uh material and maybe some
scratch
for an academic scholarship if there's
money attached to it but
outside of that when do you think this
might actually change the model of ncaa
athletics well so that's the short term
just from this decision but then keep in
mind
come july 1 there are at least six
states
that will allow their college athletes
to get paid for their name image and
likeness from third parties
uh and then we expect more states to
follow
so that that's going to again it's not
going to be pay for play
but it is going to be potentially
significant amounts of money going to
college athletes the ncaa is fighting
that
so they're asking congress to come in
and block those state laws and give them
a trust exemption
the republicans in congress have been
more inclined to do both they have more
than more inclined both to block the
state laws and potentially to give them
anti-trust protection but like almost
everything else
in congress there's no agreement and so
there's no law yet
and we don't know how that will end up
um so it could be
that in three weeks two weeks there's
name image and license payments
and then there's another lawsuit brought
that challenges the whole system and
says look what the supreme court said
you cannot restrict us from getting
compensation
at all you the schools can pay us to
play they can pay us to transfer they
can pay us to do whatever they want um
and who knows what the next court would
say to that to say wait a minute that's
beyond what
the supreme court had in mind um but i
am
i'm confident that there are many
plaintiffs lawyers across the country
that are drafting that complaint as we
speak so it's possible in
two two and a half weeks time that the
the star quarterback for
florida university of florida was taking
over for kyle trask whose name
does i don't have the top of my head
could have a big fat contract for
a local car dealership in gainesville
and nothing can happen
nothing could be done again i think
that's likely not only possible i think
that that deal is probably in the works
and i think there might be some national
deals too
thanks for calling your star college
quarterback or point guard or whoever it
might be
is in a state where this is legal
correct right well
right and the ncaa is planning to vote
this week
maybe early next week on what to allow
the athletes to do in all those other
states that don't have laws that go into
effect data it looks like they're going
to allow all college athletes
to do it not just those that are in
states that have passed laws
so it is probable that every ass
every college athlete will be able to be
paid
for an endorsement deal social media
appearance whatever else it might be
come july 1. come july 1. that is around
the corner gabe thanks for the time
great to catch up with you sir
great to talk to you richard you got it
that is gabe feldman right here
on the rich eisen show you can follow
him on twitter as i do
uh at sportslaw guy that's where you can
follow him and he's got a podcast
between the lines
uh where all podcasts are acquired about
sports and the law
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here